ibram x kendi who is the biggest race
huckster in the entire country a man who
once said that he was horrified when his
son came home from school thinking that
he was a girl even though he pretends to
be an intersectional king
he was on joe scarborough's program joe
scarborough of course the total fraud
we've illustrated that quite effectively
over the last couple of weeks here they
go talking about well racism thanks
being with us uh so uh tell tell
everybody why you wrote the book
well i wrote the book because the the
more that i that i researched
uh
this issue about race and children the
more that i continued on as a father
the more i realized that kids are
actually the most vulnerable
to racism
but with but they're the ones who were
least likely to engage about it and so i
wanted to write a book that would allow
parents and teachers and caregivers to
figure out ways to protect our children
from these simplistic messages like dark
is ugly and light
you know is good so they can grow up to
be
um whole people who recognize
racial equality and your message is that
parents should understand that children
uh are already forming opinions at a
very early age some research says as
early as three or four years old
they do and that's the unfortunate truth
but according to scholars by three years
old our kids have an adult-like concept
of race by three years old our kids are
attaching
uh qualities like smartness and honesty
and cleanliness to skin color and all
the while parents are are thinking and
teachers that
our kids aren't thinking about skin
color or even seeing it and so we're not
stepping in to counteract those messages
and we need to
nobody's doing that dude you're a
fraud
i dropped the f on there what's going to
happen um you're just a complete fraud
like everyone that's ever met a
three-year-old they don't care about any
of this stuff you then by introducing
race to everything with them create a
new generation of racists right you're
creating these
soft racists and they're not these
racists this new generation of
race-obsessed whack jobs that you're
creating and these woke lunatics they're
not old-school racists like i don't want
a black person to be at the same water
fountain as me which of course everyone
would think is wrong and there is
literally nobody in america in any
capacity in any influential capacity
that would want anything like that or
laws that would differentiate between
the races except for you guys you guys
who have decided that race should matter
when it comes to college admission you
guys who have decided race should matter
when it comes to hiring and who gets on
tv and who gets what award and all of
this stuff